elle a désormais pignon sur rue dans
l'univers du livre et la bd s'est même
fait une place au soleil dans les rayons
rien que pour cette année on dénombre
entre 5 et 6000 nouveautés sur le marché
c'est une immersion dans le monde du 9e
art à l'échelle régionale
une histoire de bulles normande en
quatre épisodes
nos noms près de bayeux c'est là que se
trouve au rép
créée en 1987 cette entreprise normande
est implantée dans le paysage de
l'édition depuis 1994 sur le marché
régional
cet éditeur s'est fait un nom en matière
d'ouvragés historiques touristiques ou
bien encore culinaire mais depuis le
printemps 2016 et le rachat des éditions
vagabondage aurep a décidé de se lancer
sur le marché de la bande dessinée tarn
ont peut-être même un rien il ya trois
ans maintenant quand on a lancé une bd
sur guillaume le conquérant sept ans
était en fait notre deuxième bd on avait
déjà fait une bd yens quinzaine d'années
mais entre temps il s'est pas passé
finalement grand chose en tout cas
autour de la bande dessinée et puis au
mois d'avril dernier on a eu cette
opportunité de reprendre l'ensemble du
catalogue vagabondage qui était un
éditeur basé sur bayeux et qui avait
fait déjà une vingtaine de titres dont
la série de bd sur les plages du
débarquement en normandie 44 et qui
venait à notre avis tout à fait complété
une belle et qui existait déjà notre
première bd sur l'opération overlord
au total douze salariés évoluent dans
l'univers aurep dont le coeur de métier
se trouve à l'étagé de cette structure
de plusieurs centaines de mètres carrés
c'est là que se fait et se défait la
matière première ou l'histoire d'une
rencontre entre un auteur et son éditeur
l'auteur vient nous voir il un sujet
donc il faut d'abord que ça rentre dans
notre ligne éditoriale qu'on s'est fixés
donc vous le disais tout à l'heure
l'histoire le tourisme le patrimoine
donc si on part du fait qu'on accepte ce
sujet en fait il ya deux pôles ici
principaux dans l'entreprise c'est le
pôle éditorial
actuellement je travaille à la relecture
d'une bande dessinée sur jeanne d'arc
donc voilà le but c'est de relire le
texte corrigé le texte c'est à dire donc
corriger les fautes d'orthographe de
grammaire harmoniser la typographie
aussi sur l'ensemble de l'ouvragé
éventuellement quelques vérifications
historique
une fois que tout ça va être bien
parfaitement préparé avec bien entendu
des allers retours entre l'auteur et le
service éditorial
ça va partir chez les graphistes en fait
on peut intervenir suite à une demande
de soin de l'auteur ou par nécessité
mais tout ça en toujours en accord avec
l'auteur c'est difficile de faire un
ouvrage en moins de trois mois
ça veut pas dire qu'on travaille trois
mois sur les ouvrages mais quand on
prend le temps de relecture de
conception et l'impression il ya bien
souvent trois mois qui se passe et dans
la majeure partie des cas un nouveau un
auteur qui vient nous voir il ya bien
souvent à peu près un an entre le temps
de ce premier rendez vous est le moment
où l ouvrage va se retrouver finalement
en librairie aujourd'hui cette maison
d'édition content catalogue de 600
titres dont 25 exclusivement tirée de
l'univers de la bande dessinée petit
nouveau sur ce marché régional cet
éditeur table pour l'instant sur trois à
quatre sorties de livres par an nous
sommes des éditeurs grand public est
axée sur la pédagogie donc la bd est
formidable pour ça parce que ça permet
de faire passer tout un tas de messages
et de traiter de différentes thématiques
ça peut paraître de façon un peu parfois
on peut dire tiens c'est peut-être un
peu puéril c'était un petit peu léger
mais pas du tout demain nous verrons
justement qu'en matière de travail de
mémoire la bd historique est devenu
aujourd'hui un véritable outil
pédagogique en milieu scolaire